as the Russia plot thickens the deep
state is going mainstream right tonight
we start with proof the deep state is
real in America and that you the
American people see what is really going
on it's about a deep state trying to
drag a crook across the presidential
finish line and trying to destroy the
man Americans wanted in the Oval Office
wants the preserve of conspiracy
theorists now the President of the
United States calls himself a victim of
it unelected deep-set operatives who
defy the voters to push their own
secret agendas are truly a threat to
democracy itself for believers the deep
state is a mysterious faction of
opposition bureaucrats in Trump's case a
shadowy cabal of Obama supporters
entrenched in government intent on
bringing him down a belief firmly held
by Corey Lewandowski Trump's former
campaign manager he had a phone
conversation with Teresa May that phone
conversation transpired in Air Force One
I believe Air Force One has a secure
line of communication particularly when
he's having a conversation with a world
leader do you think leaks are evidence
of the deep state but no less than of
course no less than 30 minutes after
hanging up that phone call the media was
reporting on the conversation that
transpired that should be an issue
security CERN that the President of the
United States is creating conflict with
an old ally isn't that the reason these
things are coming out because it's
behavior it's troubling a lot of people
those are classified conversations and
the leaking of classified information is
punishable by putting people in prison
you're Mike good morning I'm going to
let people know I'm a true conservative
right wing media sees Robert Mueller's
investigation into possible collusion
with Russia as the deep state in action
before its conclusion Trump's supporters
have already made up their minds stance
freedom across the world if the deep
state has a hand in the Russia
investigation then you should be deeply
suspicious of its conclusions if any
investigation is biased by the
Preferences of the people who arranged
it you should be deeply skeptical of its
conclusions accused architects of the
deep state say Trump is using the idea
to deflect all criticism former CIA
Chief Michael Hayden insists that
countering Trump on issues like his
travel ban does not equal deep state it
shouldn't have come as a surprise but it
was a bad idea
it made us less safe if you want to call
pushing back against that evidence of
the deep state go ahead but I come back
to my view career professionals governed
by the rule of law trying to do the
right thing for the country what
concerns you what keeps you up at night
my grade is concerned that the most
destabilizing force in the world today
is the United States of America and we
appear to be erratic and we appear to be
moving back away from the key tenets of
our foreign and security policy are you
worried
of course I'm worried
Trump has worked hard to delegitimize
the Russia investigation that could come
to define his presidency if unfavorable
he'll likely do the same with Robert
mullahs findings but blaming the deep
state will only get him so far Amanda
Walker Sky News Washington